I met with my functional doctor today and she was curious as to why you recommend that
I go completely off of iodine.
Since iodine is frequently recommended with breast cancer, she is not advocated for it,
but simply would like to know your mind on it.
So the only time I recommend iodine for breast cancer if with physiology it tests well with
them.
And typically it's only for a relatively short period of time.
Mead on iodine long term is going to cause issues with the person's thyroid gland.
Well, without the thyroid gland needs iodine.
That's part of the thyroid hormone.
It is.
You get plenty of iodine from your diet in order to deal with all excess iodine.
As an exogenous iodine, iodine is going to be very attractive to the thyroid and is well
very commonly end up causing a Hashimoto disorder, which is an autoimmune thyroid issue.
So I, you know, you have to be careful with iodine.
I know that there's books.
I read them.
Books written on iodine and breast cancer.
Every breast cancer person should be on iodine.
I just don't think that that's correct.
You have to read the studies of what iodine, exogenous iodine does to the thyroid gland.
You don't need core morbidities of that as well.